[Music]
you
[Music]
thank you very much it's always an honor
to speak at this conference and for me
it's the second time that kind of amazes
me anyway so how many of you have
actually written the description of the
talk we read not written read the
description okay so there's this this
thing in there where I say my
presentation will contain nothing but
code and as you can clearly see I'm
already tricking you because this is
actually code you can take this you can
execute it in your browser console and
it's thanks to works of a friend of mine
marketing clapper who presented this at
Jessica's 2013 it's Jay as [ __ ] and it
basically turns arbitrary JavaScript
code into this weird thing that only has
six different characters I think and
it's completely oblivious to whitespace
so I was able to turn it down into these
things that actually resemble title
slides and I was speaking yesterday on
to someone who mentioned that in the in
the title on the schedule page there's
actually I was using the literature for
AE
like this the stuff that the Danish used
all the time and it's not in here
because I didn't have it in my talk
title and the organizers came up with it
and so I thought I need to fix this but
the problem is that encoding that into
J's FARC takes a lot more space so it
doesn't really fit the title screen
speaking of Martin's work I just want to
quickly point out what I don't want to
talk about this first of all this it's
you can look it up it's
it's not I mean it's maybe aesthetic in
its own way but it's not very practical
probably and also this is not practical
I love this it's it's also been
presented at J's Con 2013 and it is very
beautiful it has its own aesthetic but
again it's not very practical it's you
can learn a lot from analyzing what Mark
Martin does in here but it's not yeah
not very helpful for day-to-day stuff so
I'm going to talk about other things and
the first thing I want to talk about is
programming languages versus natural
languages and if you've been here on the
talk before mine there was this this
idea of turning natural language into
something that computers can understand
and I find this approach very cool and I
think it makes sense to always keep in
mind that programming languages kind of
come from trying to figure out a way to
turn natural language into something
that computers understand so I have to
start with a slightly controversial
example so how many of you know what
this is where this is from so this is
the official NPM coding style guide a
part of it which talks about the comma
first syntax don't yell at me yet so I
find this interesting
I find the I so I personally I
completely you know I would never write
this this way but to me it's just a
different set of yeah I don't know
conventions that have different
drawbacks and different benefits than
what I would normally write so I don't
have a huge issue with this but in the
fence of this um Isaac wrote a blog post
that some of you may have read at the
time it's pretty
old already where he talks about this
one thing where he says don't compare
javis I'm paraphrasing sorry
don't compare JavaScript to the English
language JavaScript is not English and
so the argument that punctuation should
be at the end is silly and I read that
and I had a pretty strong reaction to
that because I think this is actually a
weird way of thinking about this because
we as humans are used to read natural
language everyday of course as
programmers we also used to read
programming languages every day but I
think most of the programming languages
you know are somewhat kind of modeled of
the things that we have the natural
languages as well and that makes a ton
of sense so to me that argument was kind
of good no that's wrong the irony and
the story of course is that I wanted to
like because this is just an example
from the style guide and then I wanted
to look up actual code examples from the
npm codebase and it was in for a
surprise because I you know I don't
follow that I don't follow that very
closely and obviously since 2015 NPM is
actually using the standard style and
doesn't use comma first anymore
interesting but the coding style is
still out there so if anyone from NPM is
here that might be something you want to
look at or maybe I should I don't know
if this possible to send a pull request
so speaking of closeness to natural
languages here's an example I'm a Ruby
programmer I'm sorry don't shoot me
I write Ruby I write a lot of JavaScript
too but I also write Ruby and to me this
is a perfect example of how a language
can look like that it's that tries to
mimic natural language in some points
please ignore the puts put is a terrible
choice for something that outputs to
standard out because it you know what
does that even mean
but ten times do and then do something
that's something I can show to almost
set my mom which is terrible don't do
that so you can show that to anyone who
is not familiar with programming and it
will make sense to them and so I think
this is a very elegant example a very
aesthetic example of how code can
actually look and just you know an
exercise for you to do in your head turn
this into JavaScript it would probably
use a for loop which is one of the
constructs in JavaScript that probably
resemble natural language the least I
would say another example this is Python
I could have chosen CoffeeScript but I
didn't want to upset everyone in the
audience so Python is one of those
significant whitespace languages and
interestingly I look that up on
Wikipedia and the article is called
offside rule languages who has heard
that term before okay a few people I
mean explain that to an American that
calls the thing where this comes from
soccer
actually I didn't this interesting
choice of words but anyway um so I just
found that funny um so the thing I want
to point out here is in like slightly
modern typesetting so since we are doing
typesetting we use indentation for
grouping things for categorizing things
for building a hierarchy of things and
the one thing that we never do in
typesetting is actually writing
something at the end that kind of closes
down that block you never do that
and so I think Python made an
interesting choice and it works for
Python because it turns this thing into
something that is still pretty good to
read and it follows a convention that
has been said a few hundred years ago of
how to do hierarchies
[Music]
so there's two things the two problems I
see with with these kind of languages
and the first one is actually probably
not a problem so at some point I don't
know he's coined that but ehh the
creator of Rails and use the term
syntactic vinegar and I like that term
because it's it's quite interesting and
so if you imagine you have a block of
code that is longer than your screen in
a language like this and you scroll down
and then suddenly it's all like where am
I where's the like how where does this
close I have no idea I'm completely lost
in indentation and so the language or
the the syntax punishes you for actually
doing a thing that you shouldn't do in
the first place which is writing long
functions and I find it kind of
interesting and the other issue I have
with it is that to me it always looks a
little bit like this so kind of off
balance in a way it never returns this
is weird so yeah that's that's some
significant whitespace this is
interesting so just a quick show of
hands who likes the the first thing
better who likes the other thing better
ok everyone else doesn't have any
reaction to that which is fine so to me
at first this was you know this is just
that's the JavaScript way and the other
is the Ruby way there's a complete
family of of languages like Ruby and
Python and Lua
that use the the snake case as we call
it like joining things together with an
underscore and there's a whole family of
languages that uses the the camel case
kind of thing and so what's the
difference
turns out there's a study I only found
this one but interesting enough that
kind of try to find out which one works
better in in the context of how precise
can you
how how's the precision of detecting
things and how quickly can you actually
read this and turns out that snake haze
is significantly faster same precision
but significantly faster and to me after
thinking about it for a minute that
totally makes sense so if you know how
the brain and the eye in together parse
words and parse sentences and it's not
you know you're not reading character by
character you're basically reading
shapes of words and so making out the
shapes of the words in in a function
name like that is significantly harder
if you just jam them together and put
some large characters in there and the
underscore actually looks pretty
familiar to the human eye because it's
almost like a space and there's almost
the the underscore almost takes up no
room so there's no shapes to detect in a
way that's my own almost in scientific
explanation for it anyway so why did
languages choose one or the other that's
an interesting question I have no answer
for that of course and to close this
down here's something you know that's
that's from an example from a blog post
that I read during preparing for this
sort by Joseph Wynn who talks about
readability in code and this is another
thing where actually you know thinking
about how we write natural languages can
help a lot because this for some reason
is completely more readable you have all
the blocks in there and you just use
paragraphs you know it's a very simple
thing and it might sound really mundane
and and trivial but I have seen code
bases where this rule didn't wasn't
applied and and I don't mean markings
letters and stuff with that or minified
code the second thing I want to talk
about really quickly is the principle of
least surprise which is something that
influences language design up to the
point
and I have a very terrible example for
you that you all know like who in here
knows what's going wrong with these with
these lines of code that's come on show
your hands please oMG so all of these
things are complete garbage
they parse into things you don't want
them to be parsed into and they will all
walk out with terrible errors why is
that because I mean it's JavaScript so
javascript wants to have semicolons at
the end of every instruction do you see
any semicolons in here well I don't it's
of course okay to write it because we
have this awesome feature called
automatic semicolon insertion or ASI the
problem is that there are a few edge
cases with ASI where ASI asi stuff
simply doesn't know what to do and in
this case I mean the worst example is
like the one in the middle where it
turns it into a division because you
know there's a beat there's a variable
and then there's a slash fluid must be a
division and then everything goes wrong
of course and to me this is like
JavaScript Achilles heel in a way
because to me from a from a aesthetic
standpoint all of this looks totally
fine it's you know and I've seen as your
reaction that you think to like this is
this should be valid code but you know
other languages simply have different
syntax rules that that make sure that
something like this doesn't happen in
JavaScript at some point decided that
it's okay to say okay we need semicolons
but then we don't but then there are we
attached cases and that makes it really
hard to to look at this piece of code
and say this is wrong or this is right
and if you're an experienced JavaScript
programmer or if you're es lint for
example you know that this is wrong and
you can see it and say okay this is fork
out and say okay these changes one way
to fix this is to prefix all the second
lines with Semak
looks really beautiful so another very
trivial thing so I like to close down
the blocks with trivial things obviously
you can see it what's wrong with this
does this really calculate the sum no it
doesn't and that's like that's like the
the most trivial example for validating
the principle of least surprise that you
can probably come up with and it's like
nobody would do there right but then you
just just think about it how it happens
in code bases and you have this this
method that or a function that does a
certain thing and use it in like 30
places all over your code and then a new
business requirement comes in and you
kind of slightly change them the
function that it does things a little
bit different like not changing from a
sum to a difference but something more
subtle but the name only like half
matches what's going on now do you
really want to go into 30 places and
change the name they have automatic
tools for that and so there that's just
you know let's just don't do that you
know don't leave it in like that change
it to something that's correct that's
what I'm going to tell you so if you're
like who knows what just out of
curiosity who knows what language this
is
it's Lua just so you know function and
then this weird
Ruby looking like syntax okay number
three expressiveness this is a very you
know one of my favorite subjects
I like expressive languages so that's
why I'm starting with this how many of
you like it does anyone know what this
is okay
some people hands up shout it at me yeah
exactly
it is the syntax definition for Lisp
it's pretty small isn't it that's
amazing
so there's this other thing I want to
show you don't bother to read it this is
a part of the definition for the Ruby
syntax it's not like the part of the
definition of the interpreter it's just
the library that parses Ruby into into
into abstract syntax trees and I already
sped that up two times
it's like 2500 lines or so it's quite
different different to Lisp isn't it so
now we're done now let's look at some
code examples this is like the
prototypical Fibonacci sequence
definition for a lisp for recursive
Fibonacci calculation and hmm I you know
I'm not used to Lisp so I look at this
and go hmm
I don't think I like this very much and
to me it's like you you know if all you
have lists everything looks like a
hammer so it's yes it's very uniform and
and if it wouldn't be correctly indented
then it would make no sense to me and
interesting thing though about the
indenting because list syntax is so
simple it's like really trivial to build
a lint a tool that will auto fan
autoformat lifts code for you which is
almost impossible for Ruby code for
example so here's the Ruby example and
to me as a Ruby programmer and probably
also to you as a JavaScript programmer
this makes a ton more sense
so there's syntax to define the end and
the beginning of a function there's
syntax to return something there's an if
thing that is kind of weird for
JavaScript programmers then it's like
inherited from Perl and I don't
particularly like it but it's it works
and yeah it's it's just there's so much
syntax in there in contrast to the to
the thing before that I think it just
goes to show that while lists people
we say that having syntax actually
complex makes things more complex it
also makes things more readable I think
for the most part at least so here's
another example this is an incomplete
example before you yell at me for
something that happens could happen like
this in Ruby on Rails for example and
it's a definition for a table or user
table or a user object that has a
relationship to photos so users have
many photos and this looks to me this
looks quite elegant and it looks like a
declaration and there's a reason for
that because there are some where the
the method call that is in there
technically kind of doesn't have the
parentheses around it and that's a ruby
thing you can just leave out the
parentheses you shouldn't do that all
the time but for something like this
it makes a ton of sense because it is a
declaration more or less but technically
internally it isn't and that's just an
example to show you how like flexible
syntax rules can really improve the
readability and and the expressiveness
of something the next thing I want to
talk about is punctuation who recognizes
the language in here yeah exactly
so this is Pascal I'm sorry it's the
most important thing is at the bottom I
should have changed that slide so there
are two things in here that I find
interesting the first one is the
assignment operator of Pascal who loves
the assignment operator in pesco right
because it is a mathematically somewhat
adequate description of a of an
assignment whereas the if you compare
two values in Pascal you're using the
equal sign which means that something is
equal and for some reason we in almost
every other language we use this weird
thing where we use two equal signs for
comparison and or
and three and that's that's kind of it's
yeah I like that and the other thing is
right at the bottom and I'm sorry if you
can't see that but there's a full stop
at the end of the program and I just
admire that simplicity is like end full
stop that's it
punctuation there are a few languages
that use punctuation I'm sorry for
another ruby example you have the bang
methods in Ruby which basically adds an
exclamation mark to the method and most
of the time it just means that there's a
it's a variation on a method that does
something more dangerous than another
method in this case it's a self
modifying method in contrast to a method
that we could with return a copy and
then we have the question mark methods
which denote that it will return a
boolean and that's nice because it
allows you to prevent things like is
empty or does do not does not have
contents and all jammed together with
camelcase
so that's pretty cool
you can of course put this completely
over the top and then you would end up
with something like this so who knows
what this is it's a programming language
actually it's a programming language
it's a pl
and it's it's a very old language and it
uses all kinds of mathematical
characters to express things and you
know just think about how weird it would
be to input this language and so back in
the days that was before computer
screens we're really a thing so they had
to come up with a printer hat that would
be able to print these things and of
course also you needed a special
keyboard to be able to put this in and
yeah that's probably overdoing it a bit
with the with the symbols there another
thing that improves expressiveness is
operator overloading and I don't even
have an idea if this is really operated
overloading technically but in Ruby you
can just override the air
accessor and that's pretty nice because
you know you can do various things with
it there are the languages that do a
Pareto overloading if you haven't heard
of like who knows what this is it's a
language that has been talked a lot
about a few years back and I haven't
heard a lot since it's dart and dart has
operated overloading that's how it looks
and that's pretty nice because you can
just take two objects add them together
and something meaningful meaningful
comes out of that and that just makes
for more beautiful code I think this is
Ruby examples again like having to being
able to do a substring on something just
by adding square brackets to it I think
this really makes a difference in how
expressive the language is number for
shared aesthetics and I'm going to close
close up with this so there's lots of
stuff I have talked about and I have
also talked a lot about I've written in
my description that this thing Ramin was
talking about like nobody agrees with
you on terms of aesthetics I have
something that we probably all agree on
and that's that this is probably not a
good idea I stole this from a tweed I
kind of I kind of like the attitude
behind this it was like you can you can
actually write Java code without curly
braces and semicolons except that you
can't yeah yeah I mean see from your
reaction you're agreeing to this what I
find interesting about the JavaScript
community though that there's it doesn't
seem to be a strong shared understanding
of how JavaScript should look like other
languages do it a little bit differently
for example we have Python which has
interface pappas like their proposal
system for new language features and tab
8 is one of the first you know obviously
one of the first texts written by the
man himself get a Rossum and it kind of
documents meticulously how you should
write Python how you should indent
things how
things should be named and all of that
stuff and it you know if you're a
newcomer to Python you just read that
thing and internalize it and you're done
that's pretty cool you might not agree
with everything in there but that's how
things are done here so maybe that's not
so bad we have a similar thing in Ruby
it's the community style guide it's not
really official but people start to
adhere to it due to the fact that the
guy who wrote the first thing here also
wrote a pretty good linter that's a nice
trick so in JavaScript we have something
like this which is the you know the the
crock Ford style guide also relatively
detailed how you should write your
JavaScript and I guess like 90% of the
communities nowadays disagrees with it
which is fine and then we have this
standard who loves standards just a few
hands interesting so standard Jas is
it's pretty cool because it you know it
just defines with a more modern set of
how JavaScript should look like but I
can't get over this I'm sorry yeah I
have no idea I would love to know why
this is probably if someone can explain
it to me and later on but what I wanted
to point out is that there a set of
languages and I think go they were not
the first but they kind of have the
strongest stance on this like if you're
writing go and you're not using go
format the official go formatter you're
just doing it wrong like everyone else
is using that and so the goal community
also doesn't have problems with figuring
out how you should actually write go
code and there are a ton of other things
and the last thing I want to point out
is Elm who loves Elm a few hands I like
Elma I've never built anything
spectacular in it but I kind of like the
approach and I like also like the
approach that doesn't come with this
huge baggage of I have to know what
monads and
and the functions are before I can
actually start writing functional code I
like that approach in the communication
first of all and elm formats of this
weird things and with this I kind of
liked you to marvel at the irony of a
presentation and it talks about
aesthetics and code that begins and ends
with two slides of chromophores code and
I want to close that we're saying that
the reason I wear this t-shirt is
because I'm currently trying to build a
greenkeeper that works for Ruby and so
if you're also writing Ruby codes and
not only writing JavaScript code please
come talk to me afterwards and with that
thank you
you